the last scene of eight mile the M&M
movie they go into the battle he makes
fun of himself the whole time because it
leaves the other person with nothing I
[Music]
was gonna buy unbelievable amounts of
Netflix stock three years ago the phone
call hung up on me on vacation by the
way hung up on me
I didn't call him back never did it [ __ ]
down some good [ __ ] man I can do that
easily do you just feel like it just
wasn't meant to be a hundred thousand
percent because I'm always like I suck
and you I just think everyone sucks and
it makes it easier I don't know the guys
like that's a very pessimistic way of
thinking down I just think it's
massively optimistic rule everybody
sucks that means everyone's awesome
let's go now I do feel like my father my
father would always tell me you never as
good as they say you are in this matter
they say you well that's for sure you
know so I do exist in that grave there's
another thing they saying hasn't been
able to penetrate yeah cuz who the [ __ ]
is they I'm just like you can't here's
why I don't take their judgement it's
not that they're wrong and I'm right
it's a big lack context nobody knows
what's going on in my bedroom oh it is
out of context babies yeah yeah
everyone's thrown out judgment now cuz
it's easy yeah cuz the social media a
hundred we always did it now we just can
read it people judge you in the streets
people judge you in the office rooms
people judge you at the cafes you didn't
see it so hundred percent
I passed on uber twice had I rode a
$25,000 check into that company like I
did the other companies maybe were three
hundred million dollars I've never said
this this clearly I passed on uber
because I bought an apartment if I was
renting one more year or wait ago
actually that was my second part if I
just stayed in the apartment I was in
for one more year I would have four
hundred million dollars that I don't
have right now and I'm glad the market
punched me in my mouth I deserve it I'm
driven by it I'm hungrier I deserved
that L you know like rocky lost to mr. t
cuz he was flashing and flaunted like
that's what I love about this game like
like I said it doesn't matter where you
were yesterday you're only as good as
your last at-bat so I don't I I never
count my chickens I don't think I'm
fancy now that things are going well
like I'm still hungry as I'm like hungry
forever I talk about everybody spending
as much money as possible on Facebook
and Instagram right now cuz it's under
priced I say that because when I built
my dad's store when people like oh man
he built it from three to sixty that's
amazing
I think that [ __ ] sucks because I
know it should have been three to two
hundred but I didn't spend enough on
Google ads when I had the best hand
forget about passing on uber when you're
investing you're always making mistakes
I operated Wine Library so when I say
the biggest mistake I've made in my
career I was controlling that car right
the biggest mistake I made in my career
was I didn't spend enough money on
Google AdWords in two thousand one two
three when I knew I had it but I was too
young and didn't understand how special
that moment was when I was buying
keywords for five cents and getting
unlimited customers I just thought it
would always be there I didn't know any
different I was a [ __ ] kid I didn't
have the experience I was smart enough
to see it but I wasn't experienced
enough to squeeze the [ __ ] out of it
that's why I'm yelling so loud if you
follow my content on Instagram and
Facebook because the ads are so under
priced and I know it's going to go away
and [ __ ] you buy for three and four
dollars CPMs to get people are gonna be
twenty and thirty dollars they're not
gonna be as affected so actualize that's
gonna go from two dollars to fifty
dollars in my brain and it's gonna
happen fast
two years everyone's would be sad that
they didn't do more on Instagram and
Facebook right they're not gonna be
crying about algorithms they're gonna be
crying about where are people because
that's what always happens everybody
here has to shift from crying and that's
what a lot of you are doing Wow Wow
Instagram and Facebook and Google aren't
taking my money nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your tears stop crying about what
you can't do and start figuring out what
you can do no way vaynermedia is a
mistake and you want a better answer I
knew it was a mistake before I started
it because it's not scalable
right it's client work it's a step
backwards for a progressive entrepreneur
there's a lot of things wrong with it
but I knew why I was doing it I did not
understand corporate America I could
read a million books and it would have
never done it for me I needed to go in
there and taste it back to the dirt
under my fingernails and Here I am two
years later and I have a fairly solid
grasp do I know everything of course not
but I have enough flavor in my mouth
right now to know what to do because I'm
not in business to be successful
tomorrow I want to be very relevant 40
years from now when I'm 75 I want to be
gangster I want 20 year old
entrepreneurs to be like that is the guy
the marathon absolutely and so I needed
that tool that knowledge in my belt so I
took a two-year three-year whatever this
run is gonna be sabbatical right and
learned what I had to learn I'm obsessed
with mistakes I do I do so many things
wrong I mean I I I screwed up obsessed
TV when I tried to scale multiple
personnel Samantha's amazing that was me
screwing up too I'm always thinking I
can do so many things I screw up every
day because I'm trying to juggle too
many balls I need to focus and I know it
but I can't help it it makes me happy to
juggle
please tell me he caught that I was a
breakout YouTube star in the first year
2006 I decided that the right strategy
was to leave YouTube completely and go
to viddler because viddler offered me
equity in their company and I've left an
enormous amount of attention i deviated
from my intention thesis to do
short-term economics and equity in a
company and I lost I lost Wendy Brock
finally came in my life two years ago we
started to try to build up my youtube
for the first time I was sitting on
40,000 user followers in a world where I
could have had millions if I just stayed
the course so I make mistakes all the
time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give a
[ __ ] about my mistakes everybody else
cares about your mistakes if you're
worried about your own mistakes you've
already lost what does it all mean
the leverage is in being accountable of
everything the leverage is exposing your
weaknesses I proudly talk about passing
on uber twice being a DNF student you
know I proudly talk about my
shortcomings right
I can't wait for more bad things to
happen I mean it because I will talk
about them because what you're so
[ __ ] perfect
I look at losing as a positive mainly
because everybody here doesn't like
losing cuz they're worried what other
people think about their lost program I
don't give a [ __ ] about what other
people think about my El it's my El you
go worry about yourself I got this is my
el I'm not worried about my wife thinks
about my El not worried about my kids
think about my El I don't give a [ __ ]
about my parents think about my El I
don't give a [ __ ] what you think about
my El it's my El and the reason people
don't like losses is not so much the
data like losses they're worried about
what everybody else thinks about their
loss that's the [ __ ] year
[Music]